how young people can get respect
so i got a great question from one of my
newsletter readers trevor
love you guys who wrote in to say evan
in today's corporate world
if you're interested in advancement of
moving up it's not so much about how
good you are at your job or how hard you
work but how people see you
well it took me some time to come to
terms and realize this i must say it's a
constant battle
i graduated college in 2012 and
september took a job with the company
simply to make ends meet
i got an opportunity that gave me some
exposure and got promoted within three
months and then nine months later i got
promoted again
i love what i do my passion is to lead
people
and this allows me to do it however the
next step has much more to do with image
i'm 25
and i've met many people under me or
that are equal to me who are old enough
to be my parents
i tell you this simply because i was
wondering if you could do a video or
give
feedback on image in the corporate world
specifically around
how people above you below you and equal
do you see you
thanks to time my friend trevor trevor
this is a great question
and one that uh i struggled myself with
you know with all of my ventures
i was always the youngest person in the
room
and i was selling the people who were
way older than me
and at the beginning i had a really hard
time with it and so my three
bits of advice the first one for you is
have confidence
and this one was so hard for me at the
start i remember my first software
company i was 19 years old
and i was selling the people who were
three times my age and had phds and all
these
all this experience and i i was so
nervous and scared at the beginning like
well
like who am i compared to these guys
and then i realized that what i had
could help them
right i don't need to be the expert at
you know what they're an expert at but
my software my product
my service could help them do their job
better
and once i realized that and i had more
confidence going in
they could smell it right like they can
smell your confidence
and they're much more willing to listen
to you where if you come in and you're
afraid
and and you're not so sure they're gonna
think oh this young punk you know
wasting my time so one understand that
you are
talented you have skills you're gonna
help these people and it's not an ego
thing
it's not i'm the best you know i'm
amazing
screw you guys you know what you're
talking about i'm i'm the greatest thing
ever
that's not it it's just knowing deep
down inside
that you can help them you can help
these people do their jobs better
the second one is to remember that
respect is earned
right if you're managing somebody who is
old enough to be your parents
then they may start off with a little
bit of bias right like this young kid
is my boss tell me what to do but there
is a reason why you're there there's a
reason why you're their boss
and if you want to earn their respect
you want to talk about leading people
right leading
leadership is your passion leading
people is what you want to do
right respect is earned so
what can you do to earn people's respect
right
you got to show that you're working hard
right this this person is under you if
they're
having a hard time making a deadline
maybe you stayed late
and help them and you're working side by
side with them
right that's going to make them want to
work with you right that's going to make
them respect you
say wow this person is a good boss
so you got to earn their respect and
it's not by you sitting
on top of them and saying do this do
this do this
right i'm the greatest thing ever you
get down in the trenches
you work with them you show them why you
were hired
right you're leading from the front
you're going into battle with them so
quickly earn their respect
show them and then the third thing is
don't care so much
i know you think this is the end all
right like
it's all about it's not about how hard
you work and your skills is about how
people perceive you
i gotta tell you man stop caring as much
about what other people think about
yourself as long as you are playing
to other people's expectations of you
then you're never gonna realize your
full potential you're living somebody
else's dream
now here's a quick example okay when i
when i was super young
um somewhat i'm 30 well yeah i'm 34 now
so you know i'm still going into
meetings with people who are sometimes
twice my age
i'm not always english in the room but
often i'm still talking to people way
older than me
when i first started meeting people
clients
i used to always have a suit on i felt
like the suit made me more important
gave me more confidence it just gave me
a sense that you know i'm a little more
professional
and over the years i've dropped the suit
you know i went
down to business casual now almost
casual i'll go to meetings with the
belief shirt with my hoodie on
important meetings and they don't care
because i don't care right when you walk
in
and and you're so concerned about what
other people are thinking about you
it shows i promise you it shows they can
smell it
where if you walk in and again it's not
an ego thing it's not saying how great
you are
but you're not worried so much about
what other people are thinking
you're not worried about having a suit
on because
that makes you feel more important you
are important you feel important just
being you
and it doesn't matter what you're
wearing you got to get to that point
and i guarantee you when you get there
you'll have a lot more fun
you'll get promoted way faster
you will get way more results for your
company
so it's all internal and for young
people watching
because i had to battle this i had to
battle this in a really bad way when i
was first getting started
age is an issue but not nearly as big an
issue as you make it out to be
as long as you go in to any situation
feeling like you're being held back
because of your age
then that's going to be your reality
it's such a tiny
issue it's almost a non-issue
there are so many more important factors
so know that you're awesome feel it
be confident not from an ego point of
view again but just know
that you're really good at what you do
that you can really help and you don't
care so much
about how other people perceive you know
that
you're just as good as the people who
are two three times your
age if not better and if you go in with
that mindset and you actually feel it
it's not like
you got to sit in the washroom and tell
yourself before okay you know i'm really
good don't get nervous i'm really good
you're not you're not prepping yourself
out but you you you actually feel that
then they'll respect you and you'll get
faster promotions
and you get better results believe
those are watching if you have a story
to share about how you overcame
confidence issues or feeling like you're
too young
leave it in the comments below i want to
hear your story you guys like this video
thumbs up below
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much i'll see you
soon
you